bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce tout nouveau webinaire le numéro
13 est aujourd'hui nous allons aborder
des exemples de graphiques avancées vous
excuse pour ce démarrage un tout petit
peu tardif aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui
nous allons voir plusieurs exemples qui
vont nous permettre de bien de réaborder
gjp lot 2 de manière un peu plus
travaillée on va en fait on va voir
quelques exemples un peu complexes qui
vont nous amener du coup sur plusieurs
exemples et ensemble on va pouvoir
aborder aussi la manipulation de données
en plus de toute la partie graphique
je vous propose dans un premier temps
alors on va basculer sur la virtu diouf
vous êtes maintenant habitués la
première chose on va créer un projet
dédié à aujourd'hui donc nous produit et
on va les chercher du coup les donner
d'exemples qui vont nous servir
aujourd'hui
comme à chaque fois soyez pas étonnés et
retenu est toujours un petit peu plus
lent lorsque je suis en partage d'écran
arriver à le lancer nouveau répertoire
new project
donc oui binaire 13 et il est en train
de se charger bon ce tournage au propose
d'aller sur le site web des webinaires
et on va aller sur la séance
d'aujourd'hui pour récupérer les deux
fichiers d'exemples qui vont nous servir
donc un petit clic droit enregistrer le
lien sous le navigateur bien se
réveiller et on va les enregistrer ça
tout simplement dont le webinaire
d'aujourd'hui
la première
connaissances pour air data qui va nous
servir pour notre premier exemple est un
deuxième fichier qu'un fichier excel qui
va nous servir pour le deuxième exemple
et donc nous voilà dans les studios prêt
à démarrer à cette nouvelle séance est
donc dans un premier temps on va d'abord
faire un graphique pour représenter des
questions de connaissances
alors c'est quelque chose d'assez
classique
alors voilà vous avez une enquête et on
va demander à des personnes pour chacune
des affirmations suivantes pensez vous
que ce soit vrai que ce soit faux
on va essayer de faire un joli graphique
est ce qui va me permettre de vous
abordé différents trucs et astuces de
mise en forme pour essayer d'avoir
quelque chose qui soit à qu'il soit
assez efficace et dans un graphique qui
soit assez propre pouvoir être diffusé
dans une publication ou dans une
communication
alors je vais ouvrir un premier script
et donc j'ai faire quitte pour un
graphique sur les connaissances
je vais regarder mon fils
chier et comment on va fermer pas flic
de la première chose que l'on va faire
ses charges et le taille diverse en
mémoire deuxième étape nous allons
charger donnait donc là les données
c'est ce fichier connaissance point air
data annonce est déjà un fish un fichier
au format air que du coup j'ai
maintenant localement donc pour charger
un fichier rers c'est tout simplement la
fonction l'aude et j'indique le nom du
fichier à charger et donc on donne
toujours un chemin relative par rapport
à l'endroit où on travaille est donc là
pour le coup je travaille et je suis
bien dans le même rêve dans le même
répertoire du projet et vous voyez
maintenant que j'ai en mémoire un objet
qui s'appelle kate avec 500 observations
2,15 variable la première chose on va
regarder à peu près à quoi il ressemble
et vous voyez j'ai donc une variable
d'identifiants une série de variables
intitulé come under score akon de scor
bacon under score c'est comme un score
dans ce corps des jusqu'à g qui sont
donc du coup des variables de
connaissances sur lesquelles on va
revenir par la suite
et puis des variables source à suhr ce g
qui correspond à d'autres types de
questions qu'on va pas aborder pour
moment aujourd'hui ce qui nous intéresse
c'est aussi de voir à quoi correspondent
ces différentes variables de
connaissance alors ce qu'il est possible
de faire je vais charger la bête pour
avoir accès à la fonction du confort
même si je prends qu est le coup fort
alors je vois que j'aime et variable de
connaissance elles n'ont pas d'étiquette
se sont elles sont toutes côté sur la
forme deux facteurs et je vois que pour
mes variable de connaissances je dispose
à chaque fois d'une modalité dit non et
une modalité nsp pour ne sais pas je
peux regarder aussi si j'ai des valeurs
mans content parce que ça pourrait avoir
un impact derrière pour ça je peux avoir
recours à la fonction frais kenna de
questionnaires donc si je veux pas
charger coup où je peux juste donner le
nom du package de points deux points
dont la fonction est là je lui passais
mon questionnaire et donc je vois tout
de suite si j'ai des valeurs manquantes
qui on voit que pour certaines de mes
variable de connaissance des à eux gdf
j'ai quelques valeurs manquantes jusqu'à
104 valeurs manquantes pour comme
hunters cordée soit 21 % de
l'échantillon
c'est relativement important et ce qui
veut dire du coup plus bas ces valeurs
manquantes
il va falloir du coup les prendre en
compte ce qui m'intéresse donc à présent
c'est de faire un graphique qui va me
présenter du coup le pourcentage de oui
le pourcentage de non et le pourcentage
ne sais pas pour mes différentes
variables de connaissances qui sont mon
code à akon j'ai ce qui se passe c'est
qu'aujourd'hui donc on l'a vu ces
variables de connaissances elles sont
renseignés chacune sous la forme d'une
variable différentes dans mon tableau
or pour pouvoir faire un graphique ça
sera pas le format le plus approprié
en effet pour pouvoir représenter le nom
de la variable sur des axes ou par
rapport à des esthétiques
j'aurai besoin que le nom de la variable
soit une des variables de mon tableau
autrement dit il va falloir que je
change le format des données pour passer
d'un format long un format d'un format
large part dont un format long et donc
du coup on va aborder en premier lieu la
fonction qui votent longueur qui est une
des fonctions du paquet taille d'hier
qui est un des package de tailles
diverses tailles dire vous avez un
chapitre dédié sur sur un analyseur et
heidi hier permet de reformer les
données d'un format large un format long
et inversement plus à d'autres outils
qui sont bien utiles dans taïder donc là
en l'occurrence je vous remonte mon
tableau donc je m'intéresse aux
variables kohn à akon g et au lieu
d'avoir 500 lignes avec une colonne pour
chacune de ces variables à ce que je
souhaiterais savoir une ligne par point
d'observation avec de colonne une
colonne va question et une colonne
réponse ce qui me permettra du coup de
pouvoir faire mon graphique par la suite
je veux donc passer d'un format large à
plusieurs colonnes un format à lons
c'est à dire avec moins de colonnes et
plus observations et donc pour ça la
fonction qui va nous intéresser ses
pieds vote longueur et quand on veut
faire le travail inverse la fonction de
pilote wider alors pivot
longueur elle est accessible directement
lorsqu'on a chargé de taille diverse
parce que le tide is high d'hier qui le
package à laquelle appartient le parti
des paquets de jeu passe de tailles
diverses
et donc ce que vous avez ici le détail
de l'aide de cette fonction est ce qu'il
est important pour pouvoir le faire
c'est utiliser d'état c'est le fichier
de données en bonne départ cause qui
indique les colonnes qui sont en largeur
et qu'on va remettre les unes au dessus
des autres
et puis il ya deux paramètres importants
qui sont nés instument et velious tout
nyns tout c'est pour dire voilà ça c'est
le nom de la colonne va devenir une
nouvelle variable et malus tout la
valeur stockée dans ces colonnes va
devenir une nouvelle colonne qui
correspond à bâle used to donc pour vous
montrer comment est ce qu'on va faire ça
je vais créer un objet comme qui va être
mes données de connaissance je pars du
coup du tableau quest
je prends le pape pour lui appeler
pivote longueur donc les colonnes que je
veux transformer ce sont celles qui
commencent par cohn underscore dont je
pourrais tout mettre leur nom un parent
je peux faire start rives
score puis je vais indiquer que le nom
de la colonne ça va être le nom de la
colonne ça correspond à la question et
que la valeur ça va être la réponse si
j'exécute ceci regardons le format de ma
nouvelle de mon nouvel objet conne alors
les identifiants pas changé les
variables source a b c d e f g n'ont pas
changé en fait j'aurais pu y aller
retirer parce que je n'aurai pas besoin
et voyez que maintenant j'ai une colonne
question et une colonne réponse est donc
pour l'individu 1g ses réponses à
chacune des variables à d e f et g
donc comme je n'ai pas besoin ici des
variables qui commence par source s'est
dit que celle qui m'intéresse
je vais garder idée parce que cela va la
vie d'anti fientes et puis ça arrive
donc je rajoute juste un select ou
milieu du process et maintenant si on
regarde le résultat
voici la variable conne pour
connaissance vous voyez j'ai bien trois
colonnes idée questions réponses donc je
suis passé d'un format d'un format large
un format en longueur à partir de là je
peux donc faire maintenant mon une
première ébauche géographique mon qu'on
veut un graphique en barres avec les
différentes réponses
donc je peux faire ggp lot de conne
j'ai représenté en x à la question
je vais remplir avec les réponses et on
va faire tout simplement gmbh a donc là
on
fait gm va faire le comptage du nombre
d'observations ici ça se passe bien
puisque tout il ya autant d'observations
pour chacune des questions mais en fait
si je voulais plutôt pressé les répond
le pourcentage de réponses j'indiquerai
plutôt position légale si l'un
maintenant au lieu d'avoir ici un nombre
d'observations j'ai directement des
réponses et je m'assure bien que tout
est ramené à sa meneuse vous ici la
première étape du graphique est
fondamentalement c'est le graphique que
l'on souhaite produire en fin de projet
ans et ce graphique en bas maintenant on
va voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
essayer de l'améliorer ya pralong pas
mal de choses à faire
d'une part vous voyez ici les données
manquantes sont représentés en gris et
vous avez ici celles qui sont codées en
ne sait pas et on pourrait se dire déjà
que quelque chose qui serait un petit
peu plus simple c'est au lieu d'écarter
ce distinguo c'est de dire là j'ai
compté mais manquant comme du ne sais
pas et je vais renommée ça bon quand
j'ai donc prendre comme réponse
je vais reprendre ma variable réponse
sauf que je vais à pied
fctt explicité d'un donc s est explicite
et d'un c'est la fonction qui a permet
de la fonction et qui permet de
transformer une donnée manquante en une
variante niveau de ce pli site de mon
facteur ici je lui donne le nom d'un
facteur qui existe déjà
je dis simplement qu'une réponse égale s
était explicite n à nsp
je refais mon graphique en fait ça va
fusionner donc explicité n'at on l'avait
déjà vu sa part est transformé l'ena en
une valeur explicite et si la valeur que
lui donne c'est une valeur et déjà
existantes ça va se jouer à la volée
alors avant d'aller un tout petit peu
plus loin je me permet de regarder les
commentaires et il y avait une première
question qui était de savoir si vaine
différence entre la fonction gaveurs et
la fonction pire option guère de taille
d'hier en fait c'est à peu près la même
fonction dont la philosophie ou dans
l'esprit gaveurs c'était la fonction
qu'il y avait historiquement taille
d'hier pour faire ce passage d'un format
large un format long il se trouve que
dans une nouvelle évolution de taille
d'israël ont été repensés et réorganiser
c'est comme ça que sont épiés votre
longue art et pivote riders qui sont
allés version plus avancée des anciennes
fonctions gave him spread qui avait dans
le tie d'hier donc voilà ça à retenir
c'est que sur ses fonctions
d'organisation elles ont parfois on
signe évolution pour les ponts c'est un
peu plus finement ou avoir des options
un petit peu différente pendant un temps
la fonction gaveurs existait encore et
elle est toujours disponible aujourd'hui
je vous montre le fichier des deux gaves
heures donc en fait elle est indiquée
vous avez ici lifesite super fier dit
c'est pour dire il ya une nouvelle
version qui est qui est plus
intéressante il ya marqué voyez le prime
la première marque c'est développe-ment
en gav est complète donc le
développement / graveur est terminée
pour du nouveau alors elle est maintenue
plus question de compatibilité
historique et risque probablement de
disparaître dans un futur plus ou moins
proche
et voyez on nous recommande for
newcomers switching payer votre longueur
qui est plus facile à utiliser qui a
plus de fonctionnalités et qui elle est
toujours sous un développement continu
on vous dit aussi pour plus
d'information de regarder la vignette
pivot quand on vous parle d'une vignette
c'est un document qui fournit avec la
documentation d'un package et en
l'occurrence je peux taper comme
toujours un jeu fait une recherche
grands grands noms du package qui me
ramène sur la page du package taille
d'hier sur lequel je vais trouver le
site web de taille d'hier où en général
on va trouver plus d'informations et
dans les articles disponibles il ya
plusieurs articles il s'appelle pied
voting donc c'est la fameuse vini
atteint dans ton parle et là vous avez
tout un article qui vous présente pieds
votre langue
lp votre haider de manière plus générale
et et vous voyez votre longueur et pull
the wider on vous le redit s'y sont
finalement une évolution de gaffeur et
de sprite à savoir que dans ses
fonctions de réorganisation vous pouvez
aussi avoir recours à des fonctions qui
sans malt et cast dans d'autres paquets
qui sont plus anciens qui sont
intéressantes aussi quand vous avez des
très très gros fichiers de données nous
l'avons pas abordé mais il ya un package
qui est un peu plus technique mais qui
est très intéressant lorsque on veut
faire du canton veut gérer des très gros
fichiers qui s'appelle data pointe bord
et data pointé ball wii va proposer une
fonction mail et une fonction caste donc
si à un moment donné la retenue et que
historiquement pour d'autres package 20
qui font la même chose vous avez baltes
ou castres donc là lé paquet en question
sont pas chargeant même pour mémoire
mais qui sont des fonctions qui permet
de faire ce même type de travail de
réorganisation de données au quotidien
vous aurez forcément besoin depuis votre
longueur et puis votre riders alors j'en
reviens ici je verrai exécuter tout mon
code
voyons voir le graphique que j'obtiens
donc je commence à y voir un peu plus
clair j'ai regroupé mais ne sais pas
mais manquant avec mais ne sait pas par
contre ce serait peut-être pertinent de
changer l'ordre de mes modalités là on a
oui puis non plus ne sais pas et quand
on présente ce type d'information on
sent bien que ne sais pas ce qu un entre
eux deux entre louis le nom donc j'aurai
plutôt intérêt pour améliorer la lecture
du graphique à mettre ne sais pas au
milieu pour changer l'ordre des boîtes
les unes par rapport aux autres en fait
il faut simplement que changer l'ordre
du facteur on peut le faire avec le adin
de questionnaires 1 vous avez l'hiver
ordering donc si je vais la dent connaît
la variable réponse que je veux
réordonner il donc j'aimerais avoir dans
l'or nous ne sais pas et oui et si je
fais que des résultats voyez ça va me
donner le code correspondant alors dans
les faits moi je vais reprendre ce qu au
delà mais juste le copier un tout petit
peu différemment parce que du coup on
peut enchaîner les éléments avec un
peuple auquel cas je juste à donner les
paramètres qui sont ici donc si je re
calcul caunes réponse est que je fais
mon graphique voyez là on a maintenant
oui les ne sais pas et les non
entendants autres éléments puisque là je
vais doucement préparer un graphique à
dessein de communication extérieure dont
jeu là on va passer pas mal de temps à
vraiment affinée des petits détails du
graphique pour avoir quelque chose de
très propre et bien ne s'est pas
maintenue - 1 sp me convient pas trop
parce que ça suppose que les gens savent
ce que ça peut bien et que c'est ne sais
pas qui j'ai pas indiqué jeudi mais
manquant donc je vais aussi me permettre
de renommer un des niveaux et je peux le
faire directement avec fc pts et oui
code on indique nouveau niveau égal
ancien niveau je vais renommée se ne
sais pas en ce n est
pas manquants ce qui fait que mon
graphique pourra être compris par
quelqu'un sans avoir besoin de savoir la
signification de ce sigle ne sait pas
[Applaudissements]
alors à cette étape là on se rend compte
aussi que pour que ça soit un petit peu
plus lisible j'ai intérêt à mettre aussi
ma les gens d'en bas
donc je vais tout de suite déplacée la
légende est pour rappel ça cela se fait
avec le paramètre les djeunes point
position donc thème
donc j'ai appelé thème legends pour
l'imposition et je l'indiquais bottom
pour bat donc des droits entre top
bottom left right est donc là j'ai du
coup directement mais les jambes en
dessous ce qui est un petit peu plus
lisible parce que sinon seraient pris
trop de passes sur le côté autre élément
on doute bien que comme under score à
condom score bacon and gas corp ces
colonnes de corse et ainsi de suite ça
pas explicite on sait par quoi
correspond a b c d e f et g
souvent il y en a une petite tendance à
vouloir essayer de résumer ce que ça
veut dire pour avoir un truc un élément
plus court pour ma part pour ce type de
variables là c'est à dire ce type de
questions là qui sont des pour steve
être les questions de connaissances ou
l'édition d'opinion où les question
d'attitude
je trouve qu'il est souvent préférable
d'utiliser directement la formulation
qu'on utilisait son questionnaire tels
qu'alain comme ça on garde toute la
subtilité du questionnaire d'origine et
on permet de savoir exactement à cette
question générale où là on leur demande
finalement pour plusieurs affirmations
est ce que vous diriez qu'elles sont
correctes oui non de reprendre les
affirmations telles qu'on les a formulés
dans questionnaire c'est ce qui évite
c'est ça donne plus d'information
possible aux lecteurs et ça évite
d'avoir du coût de 2,2 sur interpréter
les résultats
alors je suis un petit peu
n'ayant donc ce que je propose c'est
d'aller rapidement sur le chapitre 1
d'où je tire l'exemple du jour et pour
gagner un petit peu de temps je vais
juste recopier ce code là donc ça je
vais vous remonterez un plus précisément
dans leur studio ce qu'il fait c'est que
je remplace mais étiquette comme akon
bacon segonne des par les affirmations
exactes utilisées dans questionnaire
donc ainsi qu à un question de naissance
à c'était ont demandé aux personnes
selon vous est-ce que l'affirmation
suivante est correct oui ou non
l'affirmation est r est disponible
seulement pour windows deuxième
affirmation air possède un puissant
moteur graphique quatrième affirmation
le paquet foreign est le seul permettant
d'importer des fichiers de nhs sbs et
institutes donc là j'ai reconnu ma
question avec les étiquettes exactes
utilisées
heureusement notre graphique
et là bas ah oui et je vais remplacer du
coup au lieu d'utiliser question pour
graphique je vais donc utiliser
étiquettes pour l'ags dx et vous voyez
pas forcément c'est pas très lisible
parce que par défaut les étiquettes sont
utilisées telles quelles et donc du coup
bah tout va s'écrire des ans sur les os
donc c'est vrai que faire ce choix de
présenter l'information complète la
nécessité d'adapter le graphique alors
une peau première possibilité serait
faire une rotation de 90 degrés à mes
petits 4 et si je me trompe pas ça se
fait dans thèmes et de la sauvette sur
texte alors juste trouver le bon élément
pour ça on va aller chercher dans la
fonction thèmes dont axis texte x raid
ceci donc je vais prendre le paramètre
texte x1 axis techs x prend un objet de
type text donc ces éléments tactiles
label d accès donc il faut utiliser la
fonction éléments de texte en fait dans
les souvent soit on va plaider des
éléments klein des éléments strictes
pour les rectangles d'éléments texte
donc là le paramètre titre de la musique
c'est un paramètre éléments de texte et
l'âge édition
un élément que je peux modifier sa
milice le type de possibles de police
fait c'est pour dire si c'est gras
italique la couleur la taille le
l'ajustement horizontal vertical et je
vois notamment ongles et donc je vais
faire angle égale 90 est normalement un
zoom sur mon graphique mais ça me permet
un de faire une rotation 90° à laax dx
alors après faudrait peut être admis
vers le haut et pour être honnête pour
ma part je suis pas vraiment fan parce
que je trouve ça très difficile à lire
et que j'ai pas forcément envie d'avoir
un torticolis pour qu'ils coupent du
coup une alternative plutôt que de
modifier l'angle plutôt que de modifier
en fait l'angle des étiquettes ce qu'on
va faire c'est changer la musique c'est
l'acte d y tout simplement ce qui fait
qu'on va passer un diagramme non pas en
avertit calmer en barre horizontale est
plutôt que alors je pourrais dire que je
veux représenter y ici si je fais un
zoom du graphique au lieu de gizeh 1 x
j'utilise y ce qui fonctionne ou alors
si on avait déjà tout préparé son
graphique est bien calé son altérité son
axe d y
il est aussi possible d'intervertir une
fois qu'on a créé le graphique on
rajoute cordes site qui permet
d'inverser l'accès y est la dsit et
voyez là je récupère un graphique on a
inversé donc en fait on a deux
possibilités soit enfin graphique en
barres et on donne y igal étiquettes
sont garde xga l'étiquette plus le corps
de philippe quand vous verrez des
exemples sur internet vous verrez
probablement plus souvent pour ce type
de graphique l'exemple avec cordes flip
juste parce que pendant longtemps on a
fait j'ai un parent n'acceptait pas de
paramètres y aujourd'hui en plénière par
leurs maîtres x ou un paramètre y mais
pendant l'entrevue d'accepter qu'un
paramètre on dit qu'on fait on devait
faire un graphique verticale puis faire
le flip et seulement par la suite la
syntaxe de ggp lot a évolué pour être
plus permissive et permet de tenir
directement un graphique en barres
horizontales
alors vous voyez on a un graphique qui
déjà un petit peu mieux l'avantagent ont
directement tout le texte de mes
étiquette
sauf que mon graphique comme certains
certaines affirmations sont plutôt
longue et ben du coup ça devient un
petit peu compliqué à lire et donc du
coup ce qui serait pertinent c'est qu'on
puisse mettre certaines étiquettes sur
deux ou trois lignes ce qui fait que ça
prendrait moins de place à gauche et mon
graphique serait plus large
une première manière de faire c'est à
l'étape dur code d'intégrer manuellement
des sauts de lignes d'accord si ici je
prends je voulais couper entre
permattant et d'importer sur le package
foreign je lui mettrais un espace je m
en 10 h n et quand il se lâche
n d'accord c'est un caractère spécial
qui veut dire retour à la ligne dont du
texte r
si j'aurais exécute tout depuis le début
voyez quel endroit
mon anti chn ça m'a fait un retour et la
ligne donc je pourrais à cette étape là
un décidé de rajouter au bon endroit des
retours à la ligne pour gagner de
l'espace
une autre possibilité
c'est d'utiliser une fonction qui va
automatiquement calculée ou rajouter des
retours et la ligne et ça ça existe dans
le package ce qui est donc le package ce
qu'ils on l'avait déjà abordé parce
qu'on va le voir il va nous servir
notamment à à mettre en forme un certain
nombre de d'éléments ont fait ici le
charger en mémoire et notamment ce
qu'est hausse à une fonction
intéressante qui la fonction label warp
alors si je suis et on va l'utiliser
pour mettre en forme un axe alors petite
subtilité si je garde mon corps de flip
d'accord étiquette est associé à x c'est
à la toute fin qu'on a versé deux côtés
donc du coup si je vais utiliser mon
label rap ce sera donc du coup dans la
mise en forme de l'esthétique x puisque
l'étiquette est associé à x donc on va
appeler ce qu'est un x puisqu'on va
modifier l'échelle de l'esthétique x
étiquette ici est un facteur donc c'est
une variable discrète j'ai donc recours
à ce qu'eric secrète et je vais indiquer
aux paramètres la baisse
une fonction qui va s'appliquer sur les
étiquettes et en l'occurrence je vais
appeler la fonction label warp de
skicross et à cette fonction là il va
falloir lui passer un un nombre par
exemple si je lui mets 25
ça me fera un retour à la ligne toulouse
25 caractères alors là c'est peut-être
un petit peu stricte 25 caractères je
vais vous montrer ce qui se passe si je
disais tous les 50 caractères en faisant
pour à la ligne tous les cinq ans
caractère j'ai un petit peu plus de
place et là mais retour à la ligne ne
font jamais plus de deux lignes
donc j'ai quelque chose qui reste
parfaitement lisible tout en étant plus
court sur la partie de gauche et donc du
coup je gagne ici à droite
pour bien comprendre ce qui se joue avec
ce skieuse la belle frappe c'est que
donc dans ce cas on va avoir différentes
fonctions de formatage de nombre de
pourcentage
et parmi toutes ces fonctions il a
beaucoup qui commence par là bas donc
c'est des fonctions pour labelliser donc
modifier les étiquettes de différents
éléments et en fait tu as qu'il renvoie
ces fonctions là c'est ça renvoie une
autre fonction si je regardais esther
label warp 50
voyez ce que me renvoie la belle robe 57
une fonction en fait la belle le rap est
une fonction qui renvoie une fonction et
la belle frappe 50 me renvoie une
fonction qui coupe un texte où les 50
caractères et en fait ce que l'on passe
dans l'échelle des x aux paramètres
label c'est une fonction en l'occurrence
produite par label warp qui s'applique
du cou à toutes les étiquettes de mon
accès x alors
j'y suis et parce qu'on va vouloir aussi
rendre notre graphique un petit peu plus
joli
j'aimerais 1 1 marqué un petit peu plus
l'écart entre les différentes réponses
par défaut quand on fait le géant home
barre à la largeur des bars et 2 0 90e
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que la
manière dont fonctionne gg cote quand on
lui passe une variable de type facteurs
il considère qu'il ya une distance de 1
28 ivement la manière dont on convertit
numériquement la position c'est une
distance de 1 entre entre deux unités et
par défaut donc les bars font 09
d'accord donc si vous regardez ses 90 %
de la distance entre deux points ce qui
fait que l'espace entre deux barres et
de 10%
je peux gérer ce paramètre
avec l'option weave danger en bas si je
fais weave égal 1
mais bart maintenant font complètement
une nageurs de février tout est collé si
je veux gagner plus 10 passes je vais
réduire la largeur des bas par exemple
si je mets à points 66 ça veut dire deux
tiers et bien du coup voilà on est sur
un ratio de tirs de barrage sert de vide
et donc ça permet d'avoir des bars un
peu plus distantes les unes des autres
et où gagne du coup on visibilité ou une
meilleure distinction
autre élément pour améliorer encore
visuellement mon graphique d'accord
serait de me dire que j'aimerais avoir
sur mon axe horizontal qui je vous le
rappelle
du fait devenu mon démon avec les y
puisqu'on a dessiné x en vertical et y à
l'horizontale donc c'est donc mon axe 2
y
j'aimerais remplacer les 000 points 25
par des pourcentages et bien pour ça on
va faire appel à ce qu'elle y cette fois
ci c'est une variable continue donc je
fais appel à continuer
j'oublie pas le plus à la fin et là je
vais passer une fonction de mise en
forme comme j'ai chargé ce qu'est ce
donc le bal j'ai pas besoin de changer
manuellement et donc là je vais appeler
la belle personne ce qui est la fonction
de ce qu'ils qui permet de labelliser
des pourcentages là ici dans les options
de la belle personne qu'on va retrouver
certaines qu'on avait déjà vu à clous
ici de quelques mois ci c'est le niveau
de précision qu'on veut avoir
si j'avais voulu chiffres après la
virgule j'aurais pu mettre points c'est
à dire qu on arrondit tous les points et
on aurait gardé du coup cette précision
d'un chiffres après la virgule d'autres
qu'on avait d'aborder ce qui est ici par
défaut pour la belle personne ça bosse
on s'est dit qu'on multiplie les valeurs
par 100 avant de présenter suffixe
actuellement c'est ce qui va afficher le
symbole pour cent mais je pourrais
l'affiché différemment ou dire que
j'aimerais un suffixe qui soit voilà
p100 est là ça me ficherais donc se
dérober 125 p 100 et ainsi de suite
donc la belle personne sensée un
équivalent de la belle number n'a déjà
vu c'est juste que par défaut ça
multiplie par 100 et ça rajoute ce
symbole pourcentage alors qui se passe
quand on fait des graphiques avec gégé
pelote
on sait que généralement pour savoir la
rappelle à l'espace où on dessine le
graphique d'accord donc là c'est tout
grand rectangle griser voyez donc ce
grand rectangle en grisé il indique
la zone où on dessine ils dépendent deux
éléments d'une part des limites du
graphique vous avez vous pouvez indiquer
dans ce qu'elle x ou non ce qu'il y la
fonction limits avec valeurs minimum et
valeur maximum s'il avait fait limite
égal
moi je veux que ça soit dessinée de
points 10 % à points 1/5 on aurait
probablement perdu des points mais notre
graphique aurait commencé ici à 10% et
se termine à 150% et pas très adapté
mais on peut modifier les limites si
minimum et maximum d'un graphique dans
certains cas ça va devenir pertinents 1
et donc par défaut si on dit rien ça
prend la valeur minimum la valeur
maximum mais il ya un autre paramètre
qui est le fait que pour être sûr que
tous les points se dessine bien et qui a
cédé ce passe autour d'eux ces deux
paramètres expense alors pour le
comprendre
regardons l'aide de skill x continue ce
qui est la même que pour ce qu'elle y
continuez vous avez ici expand et donc
ext int
c'est pour indiquer comment du minimum
du maximum on va légèrement à grandir
l'échelle à par défaut d'accord quand la
variable et continue l'échelle et
augmenter de 5% des deux côtés c'est des
cons x 1,05 le minimum et en rajoute une
extension de 0,5 sur les côtés et quand
on a une variable discrète on rajoute
0,6 de part et d'autre moi ce qui
m'intéresse ici et je reviens à mon
graphique c'est qu'en fait cet espace là
juste avant et cet espace là juste après
me semble inutile
j'ai un graphique en barres j'ai pas
besoin d'une expansion donc ce que je
vais faire c'est donc ce qu'elle y
continue ce je vais rajouter expérience
égale alors vous avez vu on nous invite
était la fonction
et là en fait on
monde la valeur par laquelle on
multiplie où est la valeur par laquelle
on additionne si je mets 00 ça veut dire
que je veux qu'on étend pas du tout mon
graphique et donc la voyez j'ai annulé
l'expansion et vous voyez mon graphique
il démarre pile poil un le zéro et le
son pour cent sont complets sur les
bords du graphique et vous voyez que la
zone utilisée en dessous ça me permet de
garder un tout petit peu de distance il
d'avoir quelque chose d'un petit peu
plus propre
alors pour rendre le graphique plus
lisible ce qui serait intéressant c'est
qu'on rajoute finalement le pourcentage
directement son graphique invente les
pourcentages que l'on a obtenu donc
rajouter des bourses ont ajouté du texte
dans les bars on va avoir au courage et
sommes texte alors on va faire deux
étapes si je rajoute un jérôme texte
d'accord que j'indique que le faire
position égale position fils poids 5 et
que jadis stats égal quand normalement
ça suffit pas il va me dire il manque le
label label
alors quand on veut obtenir une valeur
qui calcule y parle c'est ici qu'il faut
utiliser after stats
donc si je fais ça je voudrais rajouter
là sur le graphique les effectifs
observé accor
donc c'est le comptage qui est fait par
la cik teinte et donc mon label est égal
à ce stade quand j'ai appelé la
statistique compte que la statistique
utilisé par défaut dans jérôme barre et
j'ai aussi pour s'est rajouté
l'opposition égale position fils points
pourquoi pas ce que je veux dire que
c'est que si je mets juste position
sicile 1 1 mais mines
nombre serait positionné à la droite de
chacune des bars en mettant points 5
ça veut dire que je veux me positionner
à 50 % c'est-à-dire au milieu des bas
d'accord est donc exposition fils le
paramètre additionner qu'on lui passe
permet de dire à l'intérieur en fait du
rectangle ce qu'on veut se positionner
au début à 0 à 1 à 0,5 à 0,25 à 0,75
sauf que moi ce qui m'intéresse ce sont
les pourcentages on l'a vu déjà on avait
déjà abordé c'est qu'il pourcentage
peuvent pas être directement affichées
avec gégé pelote 2 il faudrait soit les
calculs en amont mais fort heureusement
la fonction le package et gally nous
fournit une nouvelle statistique
statistiques propres qui permet de
calculer les pourcentages à la volée
donc au lieu d'utiliser ce stade quand
je vais utiliser stade propre ça
changeait charge et j'ai gagné en amont
et je vais utiliser aphtes stats propre
on va
une petite erreur pourquoi pas ce qu'on
nous dit qu'il manquait ses tics bail
parce que la particularité de la
statistique propre c'est de dire comment
est ce qu'on veut calculer les
pourcentages si je mets by égale un cd
pourcentage du dodo si je mets moi ce
que je veux c'est que la somme des
pourcentages choix de son pour chaque
valeur de étiquettes et donc dans ce cas
je m baye étiquettes pour indiquer que
ce sont les pourcentages au sein chacune
des valeurs de l'éthique est hélas
j'obtiens bien les pourcentages voulu
reste du coup à les mettre en forme un
là ils sont présentés sous la forme 0 93
8 donc si je les veux me en forme je
vais avoir recours et la fonction alors
attention vous avez la belle paire cents
c'est une fonction de ce qu'ils qui vous
renvoie une fonction m'est en
pourcentage ont l'utilisent
et si on voit une fonction que l'on
applique directement sur un résultat ces
personnes
donc personne à laquelle je lui passe
acheteur stats propre donc
à j'aimais pourcentage peut-être alors
j'ai commencé à mettre sur plusieurs
lignes pour ça commence à être visible
par contre ce que j'aimerais savoir
quelque chose d'un peu j'ai peut-être
pas besoin d'autant de précision et j'ai
fait est que lui s'ils gagnent 1 pour
arrondir au pourcentage
j'ai déjà
chose qui est plus facilement lisible et
puis pour que ça soit être un peu plus
clair ce que je vais faire je vais les
afficher en blanc et je vais
éventuellement des pourcentages en gras
dans ce cas là dans mon gm texte ici
leur pareil jamais sur plusieurs lignes
pour qu'on n'arrive pas tout faire tenir
je vais pouvoir dire color égale weight
white pour dire que je veux du blanc et
pour modifier entre gras italique
normal c'est l'option front de fès je
veux dire fond de fées segal bolt donc
pour rappel call of en fait ce sont des
esthétiques comprise par jeunes texte
sauf que là je ne les associe pas
directement à une à une variable mais je
leur donne une valeur précise pareil je
vais peut-être contrôler la taille du
texte avec l'option size si je fais ça
illégal un part égale un bon c'est pas
vraiment très lisible si je fais ça
illégal 3,7 g
plus lisible mais ça reste un peu petit
si je pars sur un style et 4 on a
quelque chose d'à peut-être car cette
fois ci un poil trop gros et donc voilà
on peut après essai erreur trouver une
valeur de saez qui va nous correspondre
et puis on va ajuster au fur et à mesure
du graphique
donc là je commence à avoir quelque
chose qui est pas mal
il ya quand même un petit souci c'est
que bas par endroits ça s'affiche mal
ici voyez j'ai que des 3 % dont 3 % 30 %
c'est trop gros pour en tenir dans
l'espace qui met affiché ici j'ai des
valeurs qui sont toutes petites et donc
du coup ça s'affiche pas bien donc ce
qui serait intéressant ça serait
d'accord d'améliorer la présentation 11
en sorte que si les valeurs sont
inférieures à 5 %
on les affiches me sens le symbole pour
cent et que si jamais les valeurs sont
inférieures 1% on n'affiche rien du tout
donc pour ça et des fêtes ont vaincu
notre propre fonction perso alors on va
créer une fonction je la paie tout
simplement f
alors pour créer une fonction j'ai un
opérateur d'assignation nous le dira f
d'accord et pour créer la fonction va
faire appel à la fonction entre
parenthèses on va dire les arguments de
la fonction de l'âge et des fonctions
qui ne prend qu'un en entrée qu'un seul
objet qu'est objets x ya pas de valeur
par défaut et ensuite entre accolade
on va donner le code de la fonction est
ce que la fonction va renvoyer c'est le
dernier élément de la fonction donc là
mon retour que j'appelais rêve pour
résultat or je vais appeler père cents
1,2 kg aux jets prendre mon x et on a
dit qu'on arrondissait à 1
ensuite on va avoir quelques petits cas
de figure je vais traiter j'ai dit que
quand x était inférieure à 0,5
j'aimerais à en dire
mais symbole pour cent
donc là ce qui m'intéresse c'est cas de
figure reste quand hicks est inférieur à
1 05 et ben du coup dans ces cas là
alors je
utilisez donc ces accueils cigale un
mont suffixe je vais remplacer par rien
du tout sauf que le nombre de valeurs à
mettre en entrée des valeurs x
inférieure à 1
or donc c'est je prends les valeurs
telles que x inférieur à 0,5 pour la
même condition que celle que j'utilise
là ce qui fait que ça ça va broyer
c'est pas moi peut-être cinq valeurs
donc savoir enverra cinq pour en
remplacer sainte
enfin je vais rajouter la petite
consignes que x ou crève dans le cas où
x est inférieure à points 0 1
ça renvoie simplement rien à cacher et
enfin la fonction va renvoyer rays qui
est mon résultat final donc là j'ai créé
une fonction est en fait que je vais
faire c'est dans mon label au lieu
d'appeler personne j'ai appelé ma
fonction est ce qu'on peut
pour voir si elles marchent bien si je
fais f 2.1 21 21% f 2.0 4 à me renvoie
de 4 mais c'est un symbole pour son df
2.002 ça me renvoie lien ici je fais du
coup mon graphique avec ça alors voyez
il ya un petit souci l'a dit ou une
erreur le nombre d'objets à repasser pas
correct effectivement là ma condition cx
inférieur à 0,5
hélas ces points 0,56 corrigeons donc la
voyez mon graphique à j'ai pu
l'améliorer sur un certain nombre
notamment avec le fait que ici j'ai
fiche que 3 et 3 donc je garde
l'information mais j'ai retiré le mot
pour cent du coup ça reste visible et
puis là c'est pour les pour les
pourcentages qui sont trop petit du coup
ils sont simplement pas afficher alors
comme les éléments envoyés ici on va
essayer de commencer à réduire un petit
peu quand même le graphique qu'on a
parce que mes pourcentage ont affiché la
dont j'ai peut-être pas besoin de mon
axe ici physique parce que les
pourcentages sont là je peux être retiré
un mon four ise parce que ça n'apporte
pas forcément grand chose
les petites étiquettes qui sont là là
apparaît en besoin donc on va commencer
à nettoyer un peu notre graphique
déjà je vais appeler un thème plus léger
la [ __ ] les thèmes minimale qui va
commencer à nettoyer qu'important ce
qu'on vous appelez un thème générique
thème great homelights m minimum c'est
de le faire avant votre fonction thème
parce que sinon c'est réinitialiser par
le thème d'avant qui lui fixe à farm
d'éléments du thème êtes-vous après vous
vous êtes dépersonnalisation
donc si je fais ceci là j'ai commencé à
alléger la plus de fonte grise et
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas besoin déjà mais
éthique mais éthique est ici et quand
métiers d art qui sont pas utiles
donc pour modifier le type de la zx et x
lab
je veux dire vides et y lave pour la zx
je vais dire vides
si je réglais tout ceci j'ai un
graphique un peu plus léger maintenant
qu'on va faire c'est dé retirer oui les
traits verticaux qui est derrière
ici on en a pas forcément besoin et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la grille
en fait le paramètre en question ces
mêmes pallez grid et il me ce qu'on
appelle une ville majeure qui se passe
au niveau des points majeurs indie
mineurs qui sont sur le truc
intermédiaires et vous avez des
paramètres pour la grille majeur et la
grille mineurs et vous avez une grille x
ou y
là on veut simplement va supprimer
donc je vais prendre panel grid vous
voyez un dans les options g panel bride
pour faire une notification sur la
grille de manière générale la quête
principale hagrid secondaire et si on
veut personnaliser que sur un axe donné
on n'a vraiment pas mal d'options en
fait avec thème
donc je vais personnaliser la grille à
un manque c'est très là qui apparaissent
et comme je veux rien du tout j'appelle
elements mes éléments et blanc' si je
règle et culte
ceci le graphique sur calcul et voyez
j'ai pu
magri verticale dont j'ai commencé à
alléger mon avis enfin je n'ai pas
besoin de mon axe horizontal puisqu'on
l'a vu comme j'ai mis les étiquettes
avec les pourcentages ce n'est plus
nécessaire et donc je vais supprimer le
texte de lax dx
ils sont simplement supprimé alors
petite subtilité
malgré tout parce que là on utilise un
cordes clip d'accord donc le corps de
philippe consiste à inverser la kz2 y
ait là que zizic on a vu pour modifier
mais éthique est ici l'un à l'âge et du
passé parce qu'elle x10 quit parce que
la variable étiquette est associée à la
dx par contre là pour retirer la kz
horizontale j'ai fait appel à accise
pointe ex point x alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quand on fait un clip c'est
que quand tu flippes en fait il
s'applique après les échelles mais avant
le thème que le passage aisé quand on y
accorde clip d'accord qu'elle x 10 x 10
km x continue ce sont appliquées avant
que coop clip soit appliqué et donc du
coup fait référence au x ou y
avant inversion par contre les
ajustements du thème se fait même si mon
corps flipper indiqué après un dans mon
code ici en fait l'ajustement du thème
se fait dans tous les cas après donc le
graphique est calculée puisque peu
importe l'ordre des éléments ici tout
est calculé à la toute fin et donc du
coup la x fait référence en fait à mon
axe d y qui est utilisé à l'horizontale
alors on y est presque on a quelque
chose qui commence déjà à être un petit
peu plus propre ce qu'on va rajouter je
vais encore connu un étrier je vais
retirer aussi si le réponse donc la
réponse fait référence à l'étiquette
pour l'esthétique fils
donc ça j'avais le modifier avec le
paramètre labs et la fonction qui permet
de modifier toutes les étiquettes des
esthétiques et dont j'ai faire s'il
égale égale vide
précisions avec l'aps on peut aussi
modifier les tickets des x et des six
grecs
non plutôt que de passer par x lab et y
clap qui sont des raccourcis j'aurais pu
mettre x décale
texte vide y égale texte vide donc
avoir un graphique déjà plus léger plus
lisible g allez gilles grasset qu'en
retirant ce qui n'était plus nécessaire
la question qui peut se poser c'est
est-ce que j'ai choisi les bonnes
couleurs alors le choix d'une palette de
couleurs on l'avait déjà abordé un il
n'est jamais très très simple il en
existe de nombreuses
si vous allez sur un analyseur vous avez
tout un chapitre dédié à couleurs répète
qu'il va vous présenter différentes
palettes de couleurs et comment est-ce
qu'on peut les coder ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que souvent ce qu'on
cherche pour un graphique c'est que des
gens cherchent à soi minimum esthétique
mais après j'ai envie de vous dire les
goûts et les couleurs c'est toujours
quelque chose de compliqué on cherche à
ce qui est du contraste entre les
couleurs c'est à dire qu on arrive à
bien distinguer une couleur d'une autre
couleur on cherche si possible et
beaucoup de revues demande ça maintenant
à ce que les couleurs soient adaptées
aux personnes daltonienne on parle de
collants blindness en anglais et on
cherche aussi possible parce que les
couleurs si on devait imprimer en noir
et blanc on maintienne des écarts visuel
encore aussi un peu marqué
c'est compliqué il n'y a pas de palette
de couleurs magiques qui fait tout je
vous avais peut-être déjà évoqué la
palette de couleurs développé par
cynthia brûlures marc caro bauer à
l'université de pennsylvanie
vous avez un site web dédié à saint qui
s'appelle kohler brive at you done orgue
qui ont développé plusieurs palettes de
couleurs adaptées à différents contextes
avec des palettes séquentielles
c'est à dire avec des dégradés des
palettes divergentes lorsqu'on va
représenter quelque chose par exemple
avec des valeurs négatives et positives
et des palettes qualitative lorsqu'on a
des données non ordonne ordonnée vous
avez à chaque fois les avantages
inconvénients de ces palettes pour un
écran lcd pour les personnes qui sont
daltonienne et en fonction du nombre de
deux palettes
vous trouverez aussi dans les palettes
pas mal d'autres palette existante
vous trouverez aussi alors vous avez
l'extension gg ci qui utilisent des
parts est inspiré de journaux
scientifiques a donc qui va vous
proposer la des palettes qui sont plutôt
en lien avec avec avec différents
journaux soit le long de cette ligne ou
john journal of medicine
vous avez ici à un exemple de palettes
utilisé par nature publishing group
à la new england par le land 7 et puis
le mot le même paquet de gentils vous
fournit aussi des palettes plus plus
issus de la pop culture vous avez ici ne
pas l'être inspiré des simpsons ou
encore de riquet mortier ou de futurama
mais les palettes qui sont proposés par
gj si si elles sont intéressantes elles
sont pas toujours adaptées à ces
contrastes un peu élevé et puis enfin
pour ma part une des pastis le plus
aujourd'hui c'est la palette qui sont
fournis dans l'extension chrome a et qui
sont issus des travaux de paul tôle sur
les schémas de couleurs en 2012
normalement je vous l'avait présentée
précédemment là on trouve la tête de
paul tall dont j'héritais mais dans
chrome à mes crocs mal le fait de
manière plus plus poussée et pour plus
de détails que veille sur bolton clause
sur internet vous tomberez sur le de
paul tolck y ait un qui doit être
il est un instrument de saïan tistes en
physique atomique et donc du coup la
planète qui est développée elle essaye
d'avoir des contrastes ou d'accords
blind side et vous avez pour ceux que ça
intéresse toutes les questions de ces
tests est en fait commencé vu par
différentes personnes suivant donc il ya
des caves diagnostic et il ya des enjeux
de calcul et de décomposition de l'émir
bref ce sont des gens qui se sont
intéressés à caumont les faire donc si
on veut utiliser les palettes de paul
tonnes il suffit de charger le package
coma
et éventuellement juste rajouté ici
alors je m'attaque toutes les échelles
donc là c'est pour finir là et là vous
avez bright's 1 du package chroma key et
du coup la palette vibrante de bolton on
sait que là on aura une palette qui est
plutôt contrasté qui marche bien avec
des personnes qui sont daltonienne et
qui passent plutôt qui marche bien aussi
quand on les a prime elle apparaît
souvent plus foncé que la à votre écran
compte l imprimé marche plutôt bien
sauf que la question qu'on peut se
demander c'est est ce que le choix de
couleurs que nous avons devant nous et
le plus optimal ici les noms sont
représentés en bleu foncé les ne sais
pas en rouge et lewis ont représenté en
vers en prose hier oui oui bonne réponse
mais du coup on a quand même un accent
qui est plutôt mis sur le ne sait pas
qui est ce parce qu'il ya plus optimale
et donc on peut essayer de voir si on
veut tease on pourrait peut-être choisir
d'autres couleurs de la palette de paul
tonnes alors si on veut regarder les
autres couleurs disponibles si je vais
sur le site de pôle tonnes d'accord vous
avez ici ou sur le site de khroma ou
même sur un analyseur directement là
vous avez ce qu au delà d'accord qui
vous donne nous permet de faire le petit
schéma de la couleur bright de paul
tonnes et en vous affichant les codes
couleurs donc là on voit quelles sont
les couleurs qui composent la palette de
bolton et on se dit finalement qui
pourrait bien lancer de utiliser un gris
pour les ne sais pas parce que c'est pas
l'élément remettre en avant donc du coup
les bb bb b se dit et puis peut-être
deux couleurs un petit peu opposés pour
mettre en avant les gens qui répondent
oui les gens qui répondent non et dans
ce cas là éventuellement peut-être qu'on
pourrait prendre ce pour le non 1 ce
viol est un peu marquer et ce bleu 4 4 7
7 a ha pour les wii donc là je vais
utiliser la palette de couleurs de
bolton mais j'ai choisir manuellement
certaines couleurs à utiliser et plus
spécifiquement ce bleu avec ce mauvais
et se glisse donc retenu les codes m44
7,7 à à diez à à 3-3 7,7 et diez bdd et
je retourne sur mon code et donc du coup
plutôt que de partir sur ce qui est le
film bright je vais partir sur ce
qu'elle sait un manoir donc manuel ça
veut dire que c'est moi qui vais
indiquer manuellement les différentes
valeurs que je disais et je vais faire
du coup value donc j'ai commencé par
indiquer la couleur du nom alors c'est
vrai que pour retenir envoyé l'agencé
ten on ne sait pas oui et en fait c'est
qu'elles sont mises les unes au dessus
des autres donc le nom on va le codé en
à aa3 7,7
le gris du son entre ce sera donc bbb
bbb et enfin la dernière couleur on
avait dit 4,4 7,7 à a
un mot non en rouge en bleu mais oui et
je vais avoir du coup ces deux au milieu
ce qui fait du coup en fait on va plus
voir l'écart entre le nom et louis 1 et
on va pas mettre l'accent puisqu'on est
sur la ligne d'absence du coup on est
juste sur un gris sur les ne sait pas
elle est mon camp si vous savez jamais
dans quel ordre médecin je vous avoue
une fois sur deux je me plante le plus
sain si vous faites un test vous
regardez le résultat et puis sinon vous
ré inverser l'ordre dans lequel on va
les saisir alors c'est pas mal de près
on un graphique qui commence à avoir la
route on a une palette de couleurs qui
marcha que l'or blanc mais si on veut
faciliter la lecture un pour le nom
technicien c'est un petit peu bizarre
parce qu'on a ici les we qui se
représente est la gauche et est donc il
se représente pas à droite mécénat
inverse dans ma légende et ça ferait
peut-être plus cohérent que la légende
soient dessinés dans le même ordre
alors on peut contrôler la manière dont
les légendes sont dessinés et ils sont
créés avec gégé pelote grâce à la
fonction guide donc retenez tout ce qui
guide les légendes
donc je vais appeler guide au pluriel et
la lune et des règles pour la légende
pour l'esthétique s'il don d'un guide je
vais appeler s'il et après je vais
appeler did legends qui va paraître des
options pour le ces pour guider donne
une fonction pourrait les options pour
décider de légende qu'on appliquera du
coup elle est et il est là dedans j'ai
l'option brise hausse égale creux etc il
m d'inverser voyez maintenant j'ai ouï à
gauche et le nom à droite il n'y a pas
besoin de tout connaître par coeur un
beaucoup de choses que je vous montre là
ce sont les astuces qui arrivent les uns
après les autres et qu'il faut savoir
s'il y retrouver donc soit vous faites
une recherche sur google
parce qu'en fait on anglais ou pour être
rivers legends gibelotte 2 que vous
trouverez assez vite des choses soit
vous savez où trouver ces petites
astuces
personnellement je passe beaucoup de
temps à retourner sur l'analyseur pour
trouver ce qui est tu parce qu un
analyseur me sert aussi à titre
personnel de bloc notes avec des
exemples de code et vous avez aussi de
l' ouvrage peut-être on vous avait déjà
parlé qui s'appelle air grassi cookbook
doncker graphics cookbook donc vous
pouvez soit l'acheter il est pas tout à
fait donner mais soit vous pouvez le
consulter gratuitement sur internet et
ça quel avantage en version papier
là le site nous renvoie sur amazon mais
vous le trouverez en france nourrit on
est autour de 30 dollars je ne sais pas
combien il doit être vendu en france
avec l'import sinon il existe de manière
gratuite en ligne
il s'appelle est retiré six dot org est
dedans vous cherchez dans le menu dans
la table des matières mais il doit y
avoir un endroit pour tout ce qui va
être voilà qu'alors d'une pelote
facettes legends est donc là en fait
vous avez toute une série de petits
chapitres retirer lâcher de la légende
[Musique]
déplacer la légende de gauche à droite
et donc en fait c'est un ouvrage on va
retrouver plein de petites astuces au
fur et à mesure qu en fait au moment où
vous allez vous allez pouvoir
si je reviens sur le menu des légendes
donc les gens de teddy
brive et à sing the order of high tech
in the legends
c'est ce qu'on vient de faire donc en
fait dans cet ouvrage là vous trouverez
en général souvent un petit problème la
solution est un exemple concret un
client nous l'annoncent qu'on peut aussi
voilà c'était vraiment le vraiment le
petit ouvrage de référence là dessus
revenons-en à mon graphique parce qu'on
y presque au bout mais pas encore tout à
fait vous allez dire je suis exigeant
bien encore des petites choses à mon
avis qu'ils peuvent être fait pour
l'améliorer en premier premier événement
cclat on voit pas tout de suite
quelle est la question qu à plus de
oubli et ça serait peut-être intéressant
de triel graphique en affichant premier
les thèmes qui est le plus de wii et en
dernier item que le moins de wii donc
pour pouvoir aider à la lecture du
graphique ce d'ordonner l'ordre des
modalités leur des items en fonction de
leur pourcentage de oui
donc là en fait on va vouloir ordonner
un facteur est le facteur action ces
étiquettes en fonction d'un résultat sur
une autre grandeur et ça c'est possible
avec fortes craintes grâce à la fonction
fct oui order alors petite explication
on
faire comme étiquette je vais partir de
codes étiquettes et donc on va lui
appliquer fct bris order si vous voulez
plus
vous n'hésitez pas à regarder l'aide
c'était un leader une fois vous avez
trouvé la fonction le mieux c'est de
savoir comment on fait mais l'idée
générale c'est qu'on lui donne un
vecteur de tri et une fonction qu'on va
appliquer donc sans dire il apprend
chacun des items deux étiquettes par son
groupe il va calculer un truc qui va lui
permettre de trier et moi ce qu'on va
faire c'est on va trier en fonction de
la somme de oui alors la somme de oui on
a un réponse qui vous oui ou non
donc si je veux trouve à voir le nombre
de wii je peux regarder conne de la
réponse égale oui alors ça c'est un test
milk pour bien comprendre qu'une réponse
égal ou lycéens test on compare chacune
des valeurs c'est vrai oui ou non
et du coup s'est transformé en trouve
pas l'os mais un chauffard faut savoir
que ça peut être vu comme un nombre pair
alors faire ça un jeu fait asine tiger
de caunes réponse égale oui en fait les
trous deviennent des seins et les fesses
deviennent des héros et donc je peux
faire la somme de caunes réponse égale
oui et donc sommes deux
pons sega louis 2548 en l'occurrence
c'est le nombre de fois où quelqu'un
répondu oui à une telle question
donc en fait je vais trier étiquettes en
fonction de la somme de connerré
ponseillé louis et pour ça je vais du
coup passé comme dans la réponse légale
week et laval qui est l'élément sur
lequel on va trier donc je critique est
sûr qu une réponse égale oui en disant
que la fonction qui sert à comparer
c'est la fonction awesome
j'espère vous ai pas trop perdu à ce
stade là ça ça change juste l'ordre
ça change l'ordre des idées le des
niveaux du facteur quand je prends le
facteur co netiquette
je veux changer l'ordre des niveaux en
disant que j'avais les trier en fonction
d'eux la somme de caunes réponse égale
oui je refais mon graphique c'est comme
le graphique est dessiné en fonction des
niveaux
attendez quelques secondes nécessaires à
ce trafic soit affichée
un centre d'instruction alors on va
relancer le calcul graphique
voilà et voyez maintenant mon graphique
est trié 1 et j'ai bien tout en bas ici
eh ben il ya seulement sept pour cent
des gens qui ont dit que air étaient
disponibles sur le monde windows donc
ils ont bien repéré que c'était une
réponse fausse et ils sont ici 100 % et
4 à 0 donc là en triant voyez sur le
taux de oui j'ai un graphique qui
devient bien plus lisible
alors deux petites questions à ce stade
première équipe possible d'avoir ce
graphique en fonction d'une autre
variable binaire par exemple en fonction
de ce qu'ils ont reçu la formation sur
j'ai pas de variables qui me disent ils
ont eu une formation sur un sourire vous
auriez une variable il ya des gens qui
ont reçu ou pas reçu ou pourriez triés
sur une autre variable binner là on n'a
pas de variables autres et donc là j'ai
fait le choix de trier sur un sur un
pourcentage de oui mais il faut que
votre trifa sens là tous les individus
ont tous répondu oh oh
cette question donc j'ai bien les mêmes
individus qui ont répondu elles mêmes
500 individus qui ont répondu au cette
question ce qui change en fait ce qui
m'intéresse assez simplement de voir
dans quel ordre représente les modalités
autre question c'est pourquoi y at-il un
point devant la fonction fun dans un fan
égale sommes alors pour ça on va
regarder l'aide de fcp browser est en
fait c'est que dans ces théories rôdeur
les trois points dessus on peut passer
d'autres arguments et ventre mou qui ont
passé à la fonction fun dons qu'ils ont
appelé les arguments
x ou y pointent fun on sait juste que le
nom du par à peine s'appelle point phone
dont beaucoup de fonctions de tailles
diverses vous verrez beaucoup de
paramètres qui s'appelle points fun pour
éviter qu'il soit confondu avec un autre
argument qu'on passerait en tant que tel
dans tous les cas quand on a un doute
sur une fonction ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est regarder toujours regarder l'aide
de la fonction et pour voir quel est le
nom d arguments n'ont point fun c'est le
nom de l'argument qu'on lui passe à
cette fonction alors si je reviens à mon
graphique on est dans le cas présent
quand on parfois on est sur des on peut
avoir des question d'attitude avec des
attitudes positives ou négatives on peut
avoir des questions de connaissances la
dent cas présent ce qu on a mesuré ce
sont des connaissances et en fait on
leur a demandé à chaque fois de dire si
de telles ou telles informations est
juste ou fausse un donc la question
d'origine c'était pour chacune de ces
affirmations diriez vous qu'elle est
correct sauf que il ya des informations
qui sont justes et des aspirations qui
sont fausses ce qui serait intéressant
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'ils ont bien
répondu non aux affirmations qui sont
fausses et ce qu'ils ont bien répondu
oui aux affirmations qui sont justes et
donc du coup pour faire ça eh ben je
vais rajouter l'information sur mon
graphique mais je vais avoir besoin de
dire qu'est ce qu'une information juste
et qu'est-ce qui est une information
fausse et donc je vais créer une
nouvelle variable qui va me dire bonne
réponse mauvaise réponse
alors pour gagner un petit peu de temps
je vais revenir
je vais revenir sur exemple de
graphiques avancées sur un analyseur et
je les récupérer le code
je vais chercher juste ce code
pour vous montrer donc là
créer une nouvelle variable j'appelle
correct d'accord est en fait je reprends
je repars de ma question de la variable
question et j'ai simplement qu déco à
col méconnu en disant lesquels sont la
bonne réponse est non la bonne réponse
est oui donc j'ai créé deux catégories
une catégorie de bonnes réponses wind
catégorie de bonnes réponses n'ont
jusque là c'est c'est assez simple je
récupère cette buse variable est ce que
je vais faire
eh ben je vais utiliser un insecte donc
je vais rajouter une facette pour
maintenant au dessus de l'autre je vais
d'abord présenté les bonnes réponses
puis les mauvaises réponses
donc on va ajouter un facettes weeds là
je vous les mettez en tuent des autres
donc c'est sûr bleus elle va du coup
deux on l'a appelée correct l'idée c'est
genre
graphique d'abord des bonnes réponses
puis des mauvaises réponses alors deux
remarques
là on voit que ça m'a d'abord présenté
les bonnes réponses non et puis après ça
me présente les bonnes réponses
oui on réglera ce petit souci tout à
l'heure sur tout ce qu'on voit c'est que
ça m'a remis toutes les modalités en eau
et toutes les modalités en dessous moi
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'il ne garde
que les questions où il yal data en eau
et que les questions y avait que des
data en bas pour ça en fait d'en face
est grid
on va autoriser à ce que les chaînes en
l'occurrence la lécher y varie d'une
facette à l'autre et aussi on voit
autorisée du coup à ce que comme mieux à
trois modalités d'un côté et 5 de
l'autre à ce que l'espace en eau puisse
varier
donc je vais juste rajouter les options
kéos oui j'autorise à ce que 1 déchets
soient pas là de même une facette à
l'autre espèce poli pour autoriser que
les deux façades fasse pas la même
hauteur en faisant ça ilna
dès que les observations pertinentes en
accusation pertinente en bas qu'on voit
aussi c'est que j'ai toujours un tri à
des modalités les plus cités au moins
citer sur peut il est bien sûr séparés
pour les bonnes réponses non les bonnes
réponses
oui dernier point moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est inversé l'ordre des bonnes
réponses et devrait avoir les bonnes
réponses oui ce avant les bonnes
réponses nous pour ce que je vais faire
ici je vais indiquer qu est ce que je
vais utiliser fc pts et rêve d'accord
pour inverser l'ordre de mon facteur là
mon facteur il est codé en bonne réponse
non bonne réponse pis fct rêve va juste
changer l'ordre des facteurs va juste
l'inversé et en faisant ça
j'ai bien bonnes réponses criant haut et
bonne réponse oui en dessous la bonne
réponse non en dessous ce qu'on voit
c'est que du coup les concernant les
quatre items air possède un puissant
moteur graphique il est possible de
réaliser des modèles mixtes avec air est
réutilisé par des dix scientifiques
scientifiques de toutes disciplines y
compris mission sociale
r peut gérer des données dans kate avec
un plan d'échantillonnage complexe on a
plutôt des bonnes connaissances un même
si sur les planches nage complexe et un
petit peu moins que sur le moteur
graphique est bien reconnue par tout le
monde
par contre sur des affirmations qui sont
inversés qui étaient de fausses
affirmations et bien certaines sont bien
identifiés r est disponible seulement
pour windows la majorité ont répondu non
de manière adéquate
par contre sur l'un porte donne et
l'affirmation le pack et florine et le
seul permettant d'apporter des fichiers
de données ce ps eh ben ça un peu plus
divisé la moitié savait qu'il n'y a pas
que fall line et dans les faits nous
l'avons vu
on peut apporter des données spss avec
un jeune mais là c'est un petit peu plus
vielles sur le reste et puis on voit que
sur le fait qu'il est pas possible de
faire un rapport pdf avec pierre une
majorité
on répondu faut - la bonne réponse était
non ce qu'il est possible de le faire et
donc du coup de majorité a répondu de
manière incorrecte
vous voyez rajouter ici ma dimension de
classe qu'il me répond c'est pas de
bonne réponse forcément va aider lecture
du graphique
il nous reste quand même quelques petits
points pour finaliser ce graphique on y
est presque mais il manquait tout petit
tous des gens on va mettre un titre
alors qu'on peut faire par exemple je
vais utiliser jugé title et je vais
essayer de mettre des informations qui
vont pas alourdir mettre un titre dans
un graphique ça dépend de l'endroit on
va le faire
1 dans certaines revues par exemple on
va pas mettre de titres au graphique
parce que le titre et minent encore du
texte dans le document gua du coup le
fichier image ne contient pas le titre
pour d'autres ça va être intéressant
là ce que je vais faire je vais mettre
un titre très résumé connaissances sur
air et j'ai profité qu'on est un sous
titre pour un ticket directement la
question exacte qu'on a utilisé un jour
il dit parfois c'est plus simple de dire
exactement d'utiliser des formulations
direct du questionnaire au moins ça plus
explicite ou g reprendre la formulation
du questionnaire pour chacune des
affirmations suivantes
diriez vous qu'elle est correct mention
ici et enfin avec gilles title on peut
aussi rajouter à un élément de légende
additionnel qui se fait avec capshaw
donc j'ai rajouté enquête réalisée
auprès de 500 étudiants
la capsule ça tu changé c'est plus dans
jésus title compte mais ce mec dans la
mise en jeu reprend c'est ici
alors là
mal il ya peut-être juste encore
quelques petits éléments qu'on peut
faire pour améliorer tout ça alors déjà
pour le titre 1 et la note on là ils
sont positionnés par rapport à la partie
graphique
parce que j'aimerais ça les positionner
totalement à gauche d'accord pour ça je
vais rajouter du coup pelote fighters
position et je vais indiquer pelote
pouplot c'est pour dire je veux faire
sur le graphique et pas uniquement sur
la partie si dessinée de la même manière
je vais positionner la cache
la petite saison d'un qui est le texte
qui a tout en bas à droite je le
positionner en bas et puis j'ai aussi le
modifier légèrement claude caption donc
c'est là j'ai modifié non pas sa
position mais le rendu du texte veulent
passer en italique donc éléments de
texte fait égal italique et ach chasse
quels ajustements horizontale je le fais
0,12 à dire aligné à gauche
voyez si je fais ça marche
passé en bas à gauche et puis voyez là
le titre est sous titre ils sont alignés
ici sur l'ensemble du graphique et pas
seulement sur la partie dessinés du
classique donc ça c'est ce que j'ai fait
avec le club title position
on peut aussi on voit que tout est un
peu coller à droite à gauche donc je
vais rajouter une petite marge globale
autour de mon graphique donc club ce
point
margin et là on voit bien la fonction
margin pour indiquer la marche haute en
bas à droite donc l'ag m margin 10/10/10
donc la margine haut droite bas gauche
top weitz bottom left et voyez j'ai
rajouté une petite marche en côte et
reims et peut-être pas très marqué mon
ait pu décoller ici enfin je vais vous
montrer une dernière petite astuce
là on a quasiment implique parce que
fini dans certains cas on veut pouvoir
utiliser d'autres polices pour ça alors
lui le recours à d'autres polices est
parfois compliqué dans des aires s'est
pas toujours ce qui est plus simple mais
ce qui marche le mieux c'est passé par
là par la part extra fonte
alors si je fais là gorille extra foods
d'accord la brique soif on me permet
d'avoir recours à mes police enregistrés
dans windows ou dans mac ou dans
d'autres
la première chose à faire pour pouvoir
utiliser ces polices là ça va être de
faire fants une porte
donc j
pas exécuter la commande mais quand vous
faites fort zoom porte à ce moment leur
extraction de vache rechercher les
polices installé sur votre système et va
alimenter une base de données qui va
pouvoir utiliser ensuite dans d'autres
les proches ne va vous avez utilisé
extra foods
moi j'avais déjà fait la procédure de
fond d'une porte par le passé et donc du
coup j'ai brigitte swing fonderie
binerie versé mais police qui avait déjà
détecté sur une fois précédentes ce que
je fais cette procédure qui prend 5 à 10
minutes
maintenant il a enregistré dans la base
les polices qui existe et plus
précisément si je fais gaffe quand il ya
la fonction find tout court qui va me
dire la liste des polices qui lui a
détecté qui m'a installé donc maintenant
je peux utiliser toutes les polices là
dans mes graphiques qui sont les polices
que extra fonds a pu identifier
là en l'occurrence ce qu'on va utiliser
c'est la police arial nero pourquoi je
propose à iassenevo c'est d'une part
parce que c'est une police que vous avez
quasiment sur tous les systèmes
maintenant sans avoir besoin de l'avoir
préinstallé et l'intérêt sur ce type de
graphique et une police qui est écrite
de manière vous verrez les lettres sont
plus étroites donc sur une même largeur
on peut mettre plus d'informations et
donc ça se prête bien un graphique 1 on
voit bien que il faut une police qui
soit pas trop large pour que tout vienne
plutôt bien pour ce que je vais faire
pour changer la police de mon graphique
de manière globale m
dentelles minimum je vais pouvoir je
fais abc family c'est la police de base
et du coup je vais appeler arial niro et
la plupart et du coup ça va l'appliquer
à la plupart des éléments de mon
graphique alors je lancerai vous allez
voir le rendu voyez
textes sont plus fins et donc du coup
j'ai gagné de la place pareil sur le
bonne réponse oui le bonne réponse non
les choses sont un peu plus étroite et
donc du coup j'arrive on n'affichait
plus sur cette large c'est à dire que
les caractères sont un peu plus haut et
un peu moins large
par contre ça va pas changer les
étiquettes à l'intérieur ici et donc si
je veux aussi l'appliquer à monde a
mangé en texte il va falloir je pense
aussi appelé à une erreur dans le génome
texte est donc dans mon gm texte je vais
rajouter family et garde ariadne euros
ce qui fait qu tu l'appliquera aussi à
la partie dessinés dans le génome table
alors ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'après on pourrait travailler sur la
hauteur du graphique ou sur ce qu'il
faut un graphique plus grand plus petit
parce que pareil ce graphique la la
taille relative du texte voyez elle
change si je fais un zoom si j'affiche
en grand la le texte devient trop petit
et en fait c'est toujours la question du
format d'export je vous l'avais dit le
mieux c'est de faire un gg c'est quand
on a un graphique finale à la fin donc
là je vais sauver tout ça dans un objet
pp on va afficher notre objet paix et je
vais appeler ggc 20 donc j'ai faire un
fichier que j'appelle connaissance point
png le graphique cp donc
que ça va être pour un document word
donc je vais dire que ça va faire je
vais faire mon graphique sur 500 et 10
cm d'eau à deux auteurs je vais indiquer
unit égal c'est m
j'exécute la commande et j'ai regardé le
fichier que j'obtiens voilà non j'avais
puis je vous le ramenez vous le voyez à
l'écran on voit si le fichier on obtient
et là la question c'est de savoir ce que
le texte assez grand pas trop grand donc
si je veut actualiser sa vous avez un
paramètre qui est ko
si pardon je m'étais ce qui est légal 2
cette fois ci on se rend bien compte que
tout est trop petit donc quand on fait
ce qui est légal de on simule un
graphique plus grands hangars le même
ratio hauteur et on peut jouer sur ce
paramètre scale jusqu'à trouver le bon
le bon ratio d' équilibre de taille du
texte par rapport aux graphiques
là je reprends encore une fois mon
graphique j'ai mis ce qu'elle 1,25 et là
j'ai quelque chose qui est un petit peu
plus si je voudrais que le texte soit un
tout petit peu plus petit par rapport
aux graphiques je montrais à 1,3 1,4 1,5
si je voudrais qu'on sera l'hôte est
tous un peu plus gros je réduirai en
allant sur 1 2 1 1 1 et donc vous allez
ainsi ajuster le tas global du texte par
rapport au rendu final que vous voulez
avoir
et voilà on arrive du coup aux côtes
finale de notre graphique donc je vous
remontre le graphique que l'on a fait
oui si vous regardez bien en fait le
premier graphique de base nous a pris
quelques minutes qui a été presque le
plus long ça a été faire de faire le
pivot et on arrive facilement à faire un
graphique on voit à peu près
d'information
là ce que j'ai voulu voir avec vous
c'est toutes ces petites astuces pour
arriver à épurer le graphique et a
présenté les choses différemment voyez
on est passé par une fonction côté misé
pour présenter les étiquettes mettre
directement les valeurs sur le graphique
ça permet du coup d'annuler ou du moins
de retirer des éléments qui ne sont plus
utiles comme l'acte dé lax horizontale
les grilles verticale voyez aussi
comment le trafic pour un sens différent
lorsque l'on trie les valeurs ce qui
aide à la lecture et à l'interprétation
là en plus on a réparé les bonnes
réponses et les mauvaises réponses a
donc tous ces éléments là en fait ils
sont ils vont participer et on se dit
pas ça à l'air de rien c'est juste un
graphique en barres dessert un graphique
en barres qui va être facile et
facilement compréhensible c'est
compliqué et c'est parfois plein de
petits détails
par exemple je n'ai pas mis une de ces
nsp dans ma des gens des mines ne sais
pas ce qui fait qu'il ya pas besoin aux
personnes de tous
mais ce que signifie ce cycle est donc
tous ces éléments là en fait vont
participer au fait que l'on dort à un
public de qualité
je vous propose de continuer sur la même
lancée la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine nous continuerons du coup avec
des graphiques avancés et aborderont
pour le coup d évolution temporelle avec
deux types de graphiques
encore une fois un graphique en barres
mais avec d'autres enjeux de
présentation et un graphique de
l'évolution temporelle avec un calcul à
la volée d'une valeur moyenne donc vous
verrez un tout ça est pareil on va
essayer de faire des critiques qui sont
le plus propre possible pour qu'ils sont
du coup au facilement qu'ils sont d'une
qualité du coup utilisables dans des
présentations et dans des articles
je vous remercie pour tout je vois pas
d'autres commentaires pour aujourd'hui
et du coup je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt au
revoir